i am very excited about this show
because i i love a good character study
and it seems like no matter how many
layers you peel back on the show there's
just endless layers underneath those
layers yeah yeah 100
is is it is it more challenging or is it
more fun to play someone like that where
it seems like no matter how many layers
you peel back there's still more and
you'll probably never get to the last
one
yeah i mean
within like
yeah it's more fun
there's always something
yeah but you do it you're doing this
in real time with the audience which is
i think uh
really interesting because
you know it's uh
there's there's a lot more to explore
there's always more to do but then like
what if this person's in this you know
what's gonna happen you know there's so
the audience the audience is going to be
behind in this form of storytelling for
a bit and they're going to catch up
and they're going to be like okay [ __ ]
now we know mike now now what's going to
happen by any chance to do this and like
you know what i mean it's like so then
they start to get even made a little bit
of a head of the lead character but it's
uh
there's there's always wonderful
challenges the the writing um it starts
there
and then having the a great cast around
to
to help support all
all that storytelling is uh
it's really it's really quite such a
treat it's really such a treat how much
better do you feel you know this
character now and do you feel like you
know this character better than you did
yeah yeah i know for sure there's
there's a lot of ketchup i had i had to
learn about within the shorthand of the
prison dialogue and and you know where
all this sort of stuff meant
um
because it's spoken so like off the cuff
and slang-like and
[Music]
like we would just have a normal
conversation this is what they're doing
so this is where the audience is going
to get a little bit behind and sort of
that but the more we make sense of it
and show it then don't get what we're
talking about and um
but they do it that way
meaning taylor writes it that way
because this you know it's the truth of
the matter so
you know there's we don't pull any
punches everything in it is there for a
reason you know we spend time on that
on that death sequence for a reason
because that's part of what this world
is and you know you just gloss over and
just sit in the room and watch some you
show the process of the whole thing that
it puts you more into that world you
know it's it's unapologetic
but it's truthful and you know there's
it's sometimes harrowing sometimes
uncomfortable sometimes it's maybe even
funny but uh you know something you know
unapologetic about taylor's writing
when someone that you've already built
trust with like taylor sheridan sends
another project away is it an immediate
yes do you still want to read it first
before committing to it do you want to
at least pretend like you're reading it
first so he doesn't think you're too
eager like how do you engage that with
him uh you know it's uh
yeah yeah i think it's
getting enough information about what
what uh the story is and what we're
diving into and taylor's very very
even more like pointed when he speaks
you know he's just like boom this is
where it is
he kind of spells it out for you very
fast and paints paints the world
and i already know his writing so well i
know know him as a friend and um
and then also working together so
yeah because i said yes without reading
one word
trusting that i knew
an idea or a fraction of what it was
going to be like and
he's exceeded any of my expectations
about
what it might have been
and will be
one of the characters in the states
makes a statement that has really sort
of stuck with me since watching this
he says you're born you suffer you die
which seems like a fitting statement
especially in a town that's
essentially surrounded by a prison
is that feel like a fitting
representation of the entire season
um i mean in some ways in the
perspective of
you know if if you're blind and you're
suffering you die you know it's that's
that's suffering this
taylor has like he's these one-liners
and he's sort of like
in all his writings you know um
about that about suffering and now but
suffering is a good thing and that you
know how we live our lives and this you
know he'll always have
whether through a character or through
actions that
shift or is going to
force at least a different perspective
for the audience to understand and
that's where thematic things start
kicking in
and you know if we're all
treading water and
shades of gray
um that is something that could be
thematic in this you know but there's
things that it attacks certain
social issues and racism and different
things and inequalities that happen in
the prison system
um but there's you know there's gonna be
a lot of different things that that are
kind of layered throughout this thing
and then um and solutions that kind of
come with them i think
at the same time that this is coming out
we're also getting to see more of you
with hawkeye
was hawkeye a character that you'd
always hoped you'd get to dig a bit
deeper into in some way or did him
getting his own series surprisingly
oh you know we talked we talked about um
that you know with i talked about with
kevin um
marvel and i was really excited you know
what do you think about doing like a
you know like a limited series on on
hawkeye i mean i just think that's
exactly where it needs to live and the
character that we've now spent a lot of
time with we don't know a lot about so
let's you know spend a little bit um
longer in the longer form storytelling
of it all to to have a greater
understanding of clinton barton and why
is what he is and who he is what he is
and where he comes from and that type of
thing and so i was very excited to
explore clint barton in a in like a six
episode um thing
it's also the character that you've
played most on screen how does that
experience feel especially
when you take someone who's part of an
ensemble and then he becomes the title
character what is that journey like as
an actor
uh you well you you you know you learn
about the world you gotta learn about
the uh you know a little bit a little
bit not so much for me about the
backstory of things but
um there's also a real confidence
knowing like hold on this is absolutely
full of [ __ ]
there's no way why would he ever do this
or this there's a you know
i knew the character pretty dang well
and uh you know
so there's there's a nice wait but it
yeah it did it doesn't yeah it's nice
that nice to know information right
and there's nice to know how to
challenge
the the information and or the story
in ways
it was a comfortability already gone and
going in you know so that that was nice
is this series mayor of kingstown is it
a story that you see continuing have you
had conversations about how you could
continue to explore this character and
his family in this town
um yeah yeah taylor has that all that
kind of stuff in his head he's the one
that's that's that's in charge of that
journey i'm sure he's probably got seven
seasons in his brain you know uh how far
it goes i don't know
but um
uh yeah we've spoken about um
some of the long-term sort of stuff with
different characters and stories and
but you know we got to do we got to do
this these first 10 first
right so that's what i focused on ahead
of you this family business do you
see
mike as a criminal does he have himself
convinced there's
a line he will never cross so does that
get blurry or like how do you view this
whole
family business yeah i think well i mean
i think the it starts off as is you know
an outreach center for as an advocate
for inmates that's the ultimate you know
initial job
but with that comes um
to to
give inmates voices and and that type of
thing there's you have to understand
other people's jobs was the prison
system itself and incarceration
um but i think
the the it's all again like i said
swimming in a different shade of grace
there's nothing black and white about
about any of this
um i think there's always
um
something looming um
you know because this you know people
also don't understand like that
why he has this power or
if you if you will why they were calling
the mayor because he was in prison for
ten years he knows how that works so why
does he have a connection with the
people in the prison the leaders in the
prison outside the prison all the prison
guards the thing because he just he
knows everybody knows how it all works
and he's just god trying to keep the
peace and um but
lines can get blurred at any given
moment and i think that makes this
exhilarating to watch
well i appreciate you talking about it
i'm excited to go on the journey i feel
like it'll be very unexpected
yeah yeah i'm trying to watch myself